house managers walk articles of
impeachment through the corridors of the
capital to the senate
this was little over a year ago but for
the first time in american history
this ritual is to be repeated against
the same man
this marked the beginning of the chain
of events that led to impeachment
joe biden declares victory in the
november election
but his opponent donald trump refused to
acknowledge it
and declined to concede if you count the
legal votes i easily win
instead the sitting president mounted a
virulent campaign against the result
deeming the process fraudulent and
contesting it in dozens of courts
all in vain the supreme court including
three of trump's picks
simply ignored repeated requests to take
up any of the cases
and an increasingly frustrated president
focused in on preventing the vote being
certified in congress
pressing his vice president to abandon
his constitutional duty
and prevent certification
once again in vain let's get back to
work
in a series of tweets he urged his
supporters to come to the capitol to
protest
it will be wild he promised
and when they arrived the article of
impeachment alleges the then
president incited them to riot
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
these scenes it's alleged by a majority
in the house
was a direct consequence of trump's
words and actions
in contesting the democratic vote as if
it's not enough that he sent an angry
mob
down the mall to invade the capitol
didn't try to stop it
and a police officer was killed i don't
really know what else you need to know
some senate republicans say they've
already made up their minds
not to impeach the first chance i get to
vote to end this trial i'll do it
because i think it's really bad for
america
others are keeping open minds
the article of impeachment that was sent
over by the house
suggests impeachable conduct but we have
not yet heard
either from the prosecution or for the
from the defense
in the last trial then president trump
was confident of the outcome
his confidence in the decision of a
republican-controlled senate was not
misplaced
only one republican registered a guilty
vote
alongside the democrats
but just over a year later the dynamics
have changed
and democrats have a slim majority in a
senate that will act
as jury healing and unity
will only come if there is truth
and accountability and that is what this
trial
will provide and if a minimum of 17
republicans vote to convict
these could be the last ever pictures of
donald trump
holding any form of public office
mike hanna al-jazeera washington